people on your website the cultural
weekly calm interviewed James Morrison
described as an actor writer director
musician filmmaker at Yogi and speaking
about his documentary entitled showing
up which sounds fascinating is about the
audition process he mentioned in your
interview treat everyone as a
collaborator not an adversary no one is
actually standing between you and what
you want to achieve or accomplish unless
you put them there in fact it's quite
the opposite on the ones who matter want
you to succeed I know this is his take
but can you expand on that I find that
interesting ones that matter want us to
succeed
they do here's the thing the audience
matters you're doing your work for your
audience the audience wants you to
succeed the audience is praying for your
success have you ever bought a movie
ticket and as you buy it say gee I hope
this movie sucks and I leave in 20
minutes because I can't stand it anymore
now you buy this ticket hoping you're
going to have a great experience you the
audience really really passionately
wants you to succeed if you've ever been
in a live theater performance when
something awful happened a light fell or
you know or a costume change didn't
happen or a set didn't turn around and
the show had to stop and the actors are
standing there they just don't know what
to do just stops right and then it gets
going again what happens the audience
applauds right that it gets going in the
audience is there the audience is
passionately enthusiastically invested
in your success it's the audience to
matters and so I agree with James the
audience passionately passionately
passionately wants you to succeed
they're invested in your success they
root for your success and you know the
the gatekeepers want you to succeed too
because now the gatekeepers may have a
different value system than you do but
the gate keep but in the gatekeepers
value system your success which means
their dollars totally about their
dollars they're very happy for you to
succeed that way
you